but you went to your childhood home is
that kind of special for you like yeah
it was so well I try to go there often
just because it's it's nostalgic for me
and I've gone every year so well there's
me and but I grew up there everything
started from there so I actually got to
knock on the door and someone was
finally there because no one's over
there no it's just chill dude and he's
like yeah come look around he was so
unfazed that I was there he's like yeah
parently you wrote on this wall he goes
also there's a crib in the the garage if
you wanted a what my crib he was like
yeah I was like my crib is in your
garage she goes man I was like can I
have it you sure I'm like what's all
this stuff and I had written in the
closets that I was in love with Cole
Sprouse full Sprouse was on Suite Life
of Zack & Cody okay I know that yes just
with that show and I thought we were
gonna be together then I guest-starred
on the show but I kissed his brother and
I didn't get to kiss cause I feel bad
for you I hate acting like I I don't
know how you do that like if we should I
know where their mouth is have been oh
my god your first kiss was with a
stranger an actor that's you know what
mine wasn't acting and it wasn't camera
mind was horrible it was like he was
searching for something with his talk it
was like there's nothing in there it's
just my mouth like and then I literally
went and spit in his bathroom it was
horrible subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going